let's practice for your product
management interview here's an example
of a common question that I see give me
an example of a time when your product
failed how did you work with others to
figure out what was wrong with this or
any other behavioral interview question
the interviewer wants you to show them
how you drove difficult product
decisions across cross-functional
stakeholders using data as your guide I
do suggest you give examples of how you
used both qualitative data such as
customer feedback also quantitative data
such as customer engagement scores from
your website walk the interviewer step
by step through how you solved that
challenging situation and how you use
data from customer feedback customer
Behavior or any other sources to get
your team aligned on a single Vision or
timeline or any other product decision